good morning believe nation today's
message is model success over to you Sam
Walton I wake up every mood miss Brazil
TV go neither one of us knew the
business true and when we can we we knew
so little about the variety store Benes
that we had to take the book that was
written by Ben Franklin and apply the
principles and apply the controls the
merchandise merchandising programs that
the outline for us but of course knowing
you and knowing I myself a little bit we
added on didn't we that's that's exactly
right but we were Mavericks even then
and we started doing strange things like
cranking up ice cream machines on the
sidewalk on Saturday night pop popcorn
on the other end of the sidewalk Hawking
anything we get a hawk on that looked
like it might have a chance to sail
wherever so obviously I'm a huge
believer in Marlin success the name of
my youtube channel is modeling the
Masters I found that it has saved my
business over and over and over and over
again whenever you are trying to learn
something that you are not the expert in
the best way the fastest path to
shortcut your success is to learn from
somebody who's already done it find out
what made them successful and put their
strategies to work for you where most
people do the opposite and try to figure
everything out themselves try to be the
creative genius where if you realize
that you can build upon what's already
come before you you can have much more
success I'm reminded of my microsoft
store and I told us a number of times in
the channel but I feel like I haven't
told him the while so i'll share it
again and maybe it'll sink in for those
of you who've heard it before when i had
my first software company was 19 years
old and i sucked and was failing and
making a few hundred dollars a month and
barely able to survive and up until that
point anything I tried had been
successful at and here i was putting
insane amount of effort and love into my
business and not achieving results and
it wasn't until i realized that
I didn't have to cope with every idea
myself that I could look up to someone
who has done more than me that that
turned the tide for my company in my
industry i was in biotech software there
wasn't any big biotech software company
to model it was such a new emerging
field so i looked a little bit beyond i
look to software in general and I looked
at Microsoft then looked at Bill Gates
and not how does Bill Gates makes an
extra million dollars now but zero to
one right how did he do that cuz that's
what I wanted to do in my business and I
found him suit partnerships and he
started forming partnerships with
companies to help sell his software so
instead of him having to go consumer by
consumer my consumer he gets sell to one
company and they would help push his
product for them the big deal with
Microsoft came when they landed the deal
with IBM so every IBM shipped ib was a
big computer maker at the time every IBM
that ship had microsoft software on it
but microsoft was already a
multi-million dollar company by the time
they made that deal and how did they get
to multi millionaire status it was by
making other partnerships smaller
partnerships and so I took that strategy
and applied it to my business to and
started forming partnerships the first
partnership deal that I struck was with
a company in Europe and they agreed to
pay us 13 and a half thousand dollars up
front and that may not seem like a lot
of money but to me for a guy making
three hundred dollars a month that that
was hitting the jackpot and more
important than that I now had a system
to follow where I can do that again and
again and again for more partnerships
get paid more money and they would help
then sell our software for us and so
just that change in direction that
change in approach instead of me trying
to cope with every single idea feeling
like I need to be the creative genius
changing that mindset saying who else
has done this before in history and how
can I model their success that saved my
business I'm forever grateful to Bill
Gates even though I've never met him
because he he kept me on the path of
entrepreneurship because I modeled his
success and so whatever challenge you're
going up against now whatever obstacles
in your way it has already been solved
it has already been solved by somebody
else in your industry or in a different
industry all you have to do is look at
how did they solve it and how can you
apply to your business today model
so the question of the day today is who
do you model I'm really curious to find
out leave it in the comments below and
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presso expresso give
me go